Once Upon a Time Europe was the most
domineering force in the entire world
they controlled swads of land across the
entire Globe extracting resources
Manpower and wealth for their own
Prosperity since then though Europe's
outdated and predatory system of
colonialism and imperialism has been
replaced by capitalism which is
ironically also rather predatory and for
the longest time it seemed that Europe
was thriving in this new world order as
well they had dozens of heavy weights in
the Fortune 500 in the pharmaceutical
banking energy and fashion Industries
but there is one industry in which
Europe has completely dropped the ball
in Tech despite being some of the most
modern and powerful countries in the
entire world Europe only has two tech
companies in the entire Fortune 100
companies that you probably never even
heard of asml and sap and while asml and
sap are no doubt champions in their own
right put next to American big Tech
Champions they pale in comparison asml
currently stands at a $272 billion
market cap while sap stands at $181
billion market cap for perspective there
have been days that Apple has lost Sap's
entire market cap in a singular day and
that's just comparing the top players if
we go down the list it looks even worse
for Europe Europe's eighth largest tech
company doesn't even make the Fortune
500 list and the only globally relevant
European Tech startup that immediately
comes to mind is Spotify now I can
already hear some of you saying that
this is actually a good thing it's a
good thing that Europe's economy isn't
dominated by dozens of big Tech
monopolistic corporations and I
definitely get where you're coming from
but at the same time this is very much a
massive disadvantage for Europe as
they're starting to be viewed as the
second world when it comes to Tech so
how in the world did Europe get left so
far behind
[Music]
behind now it's easy to be apathetic to
Big tech companies boohoo Europe doesn't
have a meate tech company that controls
every aspect of our lives but one of the
positives of big Tech is that they've
created millions of super high-paying
jobs however this doesn't seem to have
really affected Europe nearly as much in
fact when it comes to compensation
European Tech workers are only earning
about half as much as American Tech
workers for these same jobs take
entry-level software Engineers for
example in the top American Tech cities
we're talking about 128 in San Francisco
and 133 in New York City in the top
European Tech cities however we're
talking about 63 in London and 60 in
Amsterdam and this disparity goes all
the way to the top for director of
engineering we're talking about 202 in
San Francisco and 174 in NYC but for the
same job it's only 124 in London and 101
in Amsterdam and let's not forget it's
not like London is cheap to live in if
anything London is a tier 2 City in
terms of cost of living for which Tech
generally pays 15% less but not 50% less
you might be saying that that's because
Europe doesn't have Ultra Rich tech
companies that can pay as much and
you're right but almost every American
tech company has a European base and
they're now using Europe as a cheap
labor market and I'm not even talking
about Eastern European countries like
Poland and Ukraine I'm actually talking
about top cities like London take
Facebook for example for level five
Engineers they pay average compensation
of
$421,000 in the United States you want
to guess how much they pay L5 engineers
in London though well for the most part
they pay something in the low 200s some
London L5 Engineers even earn as little
as the 130s now I'm not saying that you
should feel bad for any of these people
all of them are obviously extremely well
off whether they're making 400 or 200 or
130 but putting aside these specific
numbers think about it from a macro
scale imagine you're the United Kingdom
for centuries you ruled the entire world
people used to say that the Sun never
set on the British Empire you're not as
powerful as you once used to be but
you're still a world power after all you
still have the sixth largest GDP in the
entire world coming in at $3 trillion
but despite all of that America has the
audacity to come into your country and
pay your citizens half the compensation
or less I don't know about you but if I
was the UK I'd feel pretty insulted but
it gets even worse you see European Tech
not only Compares poorly to America but
it also Compares poorly to the
developing World take Google India for
example Google generally pays slightly
less than Facebook like 5% less or so
but you want to guess how much Ali
Google Engineers are making in India
well a lot of them are earning high 100s
aka the top 25% of Indian Fang Engineers
are making more than the bottom 25% of
European Fang engineers and that isn't
meant as a hit against India if anything
it's actually the exact opposite all
this shows is that India is very much
heading in the direction of becoming a
first world country while Europe is
heading in the exact opposite direction
all because of tech and all of that is
just looking at the UK one of the most
prosperous European countries most
European countries compare even less
favorably to the modern tech industry
which brings us to the question of what
in the world happened to
Europe researching for this video I was
hoping to find some sort of pivotal
event that completely changed the
trajectories of American Tech and
European Tech but there was no such
singular event rather it seems that the
current state of European Tech is very
much a culmination of Decades of
evolving European culture you see
Europeans tend to be a lot more
practical they actually want to live
life and not just live to work and this
ideology has been worked into their laws
themselves America is the only Advanced
economy that does not guarantee paid
time off all EU countries however
mandate that employers provide at least
20 paid vacation days every year and
many countries like France actually
mandate 30 paid vacation days or 6 weeks
per year and all of that is in addition
to paid public holidays and usually
unlimited sick days what this means is
that American Tech workers only get
about 2 to 3 weeks of vacation time
while European Tech workers usually get
7 to 8 weeks of vacation time the amount
of vacation time that Americans get
doesn't even matter though because
Americans just don't take vacations many
tech companies like Netflix actually
offer unlimited pay time off because
they're extremely confident that their
employees won't abuse it in fact the
average American with unlimited paytime
off only takes 10 days or 2 weeks off
per year Europeans on the other hand
actually tend to use most if not all of
their vacation time in France for
example it's common to take off all of
August and that's just vacation time
even when they're not on vacation
Europeans only tend to work 35 to 40
hours per week while Americans tend to
work 40 to 45 hours and if you look at
the more competitive Americans and
places like India China it's actually
more like 70 to 80 hours now Studies
have shown that the European approach
produces more productivity per hour but
in terms of overall productivity
American Tech workers generally come out
far ahead of European Tech workers
simply because they work 500 to 1,000
hours more per year as such tech
companies are unsurprisingly willing to
also pay American Engineers a lot more
than European Engineers but actual
productivity only tells half the story
The the other half is due to vastly
different compensation laws and policies
especially when it comes to benefits in
America on top of your cash salary you
can usually expect a bonus up to a 3%
match on a 401K plan and discounted
health insurance in Europe however you
can usually expect a bonus up to a 10%
contribution to a pension fund and fully
paid for Private health insurance
Europeans tend to get far more small
benefits here and there in general and
that's just what's apparent on the
compensation package behind this SC
European employers have to pay far more
in taxes take Social Security tax for
example American employers only have to
pay 7.65% in Social Security tax in the
UK employers have to pay
13.8% in Germany employers have to pay
20% and in France employers have to pay
a whopping
45% companies are obviously going to
take all of this into account when
making job offers to Europeans leading
to far less upfront compensation so all
of that kind of explains the
quantitative side of lower European
compensation but the reality is that the
biggest Factor leading to Europe being
left behind actually has nothing to do
with objective
[Music]
reasoning it's easy to write off the
European tech industry using some sort
of quantitative measure whether it's
Europeans working less or higher taxes
or more benefits or whatever the case
may be but the truth is that there is
only one reason why the disparity
between American Tech and European Tech
is so large it's because Europe has
something that America never had and
likely never will contentment whether
it's on a macro scale where big tech
companies are trying to grow to billions
of users or on a micro scale where
employees are buying for the next
promotion or bonus Europeans often just
don't care at least not nearly as much
as Americans take employee tenure for
example the median employee tenure in
America is 4.8 years while the median
employee tenure in Europe is over double
at 9.8 years this is primarily because
Europeans are far less likely to
constantly Jump Around companies looking
for the best compensation and title
possible and that isn't to say that
Europeans aim low they absolutely do
want a solid income healthy benefits and
a comfortable retirement but that's also
all they want they're not looking for
the Mega Millions that American Tech
workers are often after and likely the
best example of this is stock-based
compensation you know how we were
talking about European Tech workers only
being paid half as much as American Tech
workers well that's only if you look at
total compensation if you're just
comparing cash salary and bonus European
Tech compensation is actually quite
comparable to American Tech compensation
especially when you factoring more paid
time off larger retirement contributions
and better health insurance where
European compensation actually falls way
behind is stock-based compensation let's
go back to our American al5 Facebook
engineer for example out of their total
comp of
$421,000 $183,000 or nearly half is just
stock in London however these same
Engineers are often paid as little as 20
to 30k in stock per year or only about
15% as much as their American
counterparts this isn't because big Tech
is snubbing these employees but largely
because Europeans tend to Value stock
compensation far less than Americans in
America especially with startups
Engineers are often willing to forgo
their entire cash compensation or take a
very modest salary in exchange for more
equity in Europe however it's the exact
opposite most would much rather have a
high consistent and reliable cash income
instead of volatile equity and when you
take the most lucrative part of tech
compensation out of the equation well
European compensation is what you're
left with and the higher you go in title
the bigger the disparity European L7
Facebook Engineers for example are
earning up to half a million dollar less
and honestly I don't see this changing
as this isn't just the case with tech
but basically every industry us doctors
average over 300 while many European
doctors don't even cross 100 US lawyers
often cross 200 while European lawyers
often don't cross 100 it's the same
Trend that's carrying over to the tech
industry as well just at a different
level and given that the Europeans that
do want to earn more money and start big
companies just to come to America it's
likely that this disparity will only
grow with time but hey maybe that's not
such a bad thing Europe may not be home
to the highest salaries or the biggest
tech companies but they are home to the
happiest people on the planet and in the
end that's what really matters with
historically High interest rates the
appeal of bills and bonds is higher than
ever yet traditional brokerages haven't
really adapted with the times they still
expect people to use clunky Bond tables
scroll through long overwhelming lists
and and even use Virtual keyboards till
recently and that's why we created our
own modern Bond platform Silo at Silo we
prioritize the user experience and the
ease of finding and investing in the
issuers you know and trust so that you
too can easily lock in high yields also
choosing a strong user experience does
not mean sacrificing on safety every
Salo account is insured by $500,000 in
sipc insurance and $2.5 million in Ft IC
Insurance also all funds deposited on
the platform will be maintained by our
trusted custodian interactive brokers
who has experienced managing $373
billion worth of assets over the past 45
years so if you're looking for a modern
way to invest in bonds please consider
checking out Silo in the description
below someone else that's getting left
behind by the tech industry is the
American middle class check out this
video to learn more but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one